hey 42 here there are some remarkable
cities dotted around the world but what
about the ones that have been consigned
to the Past today we look at nine
amazing cities that will wonned bustling
clubs full of life but are now a mere
shell of their former selves forever
lost to history
our first lost city is in southwestern
USA and it was probably abandoned by the
14th century white immigrants
rediscovered it in the late 18-hundreds
the local Native Americans obviously
knew of its existence but left the
sacred ancestral sites uninhabited Mesa
Verde in Colorado is a large National
Park and it holds around 4,300 ancient
dwellings with the largest being cliff
palace the giant 150 room structure
follows the shallow curve of an
overhanging cliff and with its sandstone
wall looks like it's been carved right
out of the rock and if you're thinking
wait that's not a city
remember this was built after a long
history of nomadic traveling the people
would constantly be on the move
following the seasons and the various
animals that they hunted so to build
something this big and this permanent
was impressive it would be just like you
coming from a tiny farming village and
getting off the train in New York
historians call the people Pueblo uns
from the Spanish Pueblo meaning town
they started building permanent
structures in around 750 ad as a way to
store food for longer probably to get
some down time when they were sick of
running after Buffalo our settlement
grew they increased their reliance on
farming since they could no longer move
with the migrating animals plus the more
that they built the more wood they
needed and so the less forest there was
for them to forage in hunting so what
happened to its inhabitants well unlike
many great Native American peoples it
wasn't the early settlers who drove them
out of their homes more likely it was a
changing climate and the series of mega
droughts in the 13th century which
hindered their farming no matter how
cool your houses
you're not going to stay if you can't
eat we're heading around the other side
of the world now to ancient Mesopotamia
which is considered by many to be the
cradle of civilization with creations
such as writing metallurgy and farming
they started a long journey that led to
you being able to play Angry Birds on
your smartphone whilst eating a Big Mac
and Mesopotamia housed one of mankind's
greatest cities babylon at its peak it
had a population of over 200,000 people
which was around 0.003 percent of the
world population or to put that into
modern terms it will be over 20 million
people only Tokyo is bigger than that
right now the city has a long and
violent story and empires have risen and
fallen around it it appeared in history
around 2300 BC although who built it and
exactly when our a little fuzzy since
three thousand years of bad filing
government it's kind of difficult to
find the original planning application
after 2000 BC the rise of the Babylonian
Empire began and the city became the key
holy place of Mesopotamia and was likely
the largest city in the world
at that point it went for a bit of a
slump but hey we all do and then it grew
again to greatness between 600 and 300
BC it's been ruled by leaders such as
Nebuchadnezzar who created the famous
Hanging Gardens of Babylon and by
Alexander the Great when Alexander died
the battle to take over his power
basically emptied the city I can only
imagine his wake was full of big egos
and an awful lot of wine it was also
supposedly the home of the mythical
Tower of Babel which was written about
in the book of Genesis the Tower was
built to reach all the way up into the
heavens and the architects hoped it
would act as a sign that their people
would remain and not be spread out
across the world but then God came down
and from a spanner in the work by making
everyone speak a different language so
they had to wander off to separate
corners of the earth you could read this
all as an allegory showing that
Mesopotamia really was the birthplace of
all civilizations
so where is Babylon now well it's ruins
lie in modern-day Iraq in the 1980s
Saddam Hussein started to rebuild part
of it to demonstrate the great history
of the Arab region he also decided to
add a huge portrait of himself and
Nebuchadnezzar and inscribed this was
built by Saddam Hussein son of
Nebuchadnezzar to glorify Iraq if you're
going to be a twisted evil dictator you
may as well do it with style now we
travel south across the Mediterranean to
reach Carthage a lost city on the tip of
Tunisia at Africa's point closest to
Italy the area is now a suburb of the
Tunisian capital Tunis but it was once a
great power hub of the area the base of
a naval Empire the city was created by
Phoenician colonists in about 814 BC
traveling over from their home in what
is now known as Lebanon they were led by
their queen Dido
no not the late 90s British pop artist
Queen Dido was worshipped for many years
after her death this was largely due to
her flamboyant end a rival King was
threatening to invade Carthage if she
didn't consent to marry him she built a
huge pyre be tending that she was
burning everything that reminded her of
her previous now deceased husband but at
the final moment she left onto the fire
and fell onto her own sword
now that's what I call a rejection it
makes someone not showing up to a date
seem to have a mild do you want to go
out with me I'd rather fall on my own
sword while simultaneously enveloped in
flames think I'll take that as a no then
Carthage was actually very difficult to
attack them with its massive Navy of 220
warships and an enormous 37 kilometres
of walls surrounding it in fact it
wasn't until 146 BC that it first fell
the Romans who were in a pretty bad mood
from dealing with Hannibal the
Carthaginian military commander not the
cannibal for 15 years took the city they
then burnt the ships unsold some 50,000
Carthaginians
into slavery the Romans then built it up
into one of the largest cities
their empire the Vandals took it over
for a while but eventually in 698 ad
there was a second great Battle of
Carthage the armies of Umayyad one of
the largest Islamic caliphates
completely destroyed the city cutting
off its water
tearing down the walls and wrecking the
harbor it really ruined its retail value
our next city was left half abandoned in
the jungle for around 300 years but has
now become one of the world's largest
tourist attractions and kawatte is the
largest religious monument in the world
and is the pride of Cambodia even
featuring on their national flag
constructed in the 12th century by king
Surya Varma in a second it was
originally designed as a Hindu temple
but had become Buddhist by the end of
the century this was mainly due to a
change in the beliefs of the land the
beautiful temples we see now are only a
small part of what used to exist
Anker was in fact the largest
pre-industrial city in the world and
between 1010 and 1220 it held at least
0.1 percent of the world's population
within it 1,000 square kilometers sprawl
there are a number of theories as to why
this architectural marvel ended up
mostly deserted there was an uprising
against a ruler from Siam in 1431 since
the Siamese had taken control of the
city some 80 years earlier this probably
led a large proportion of people to
migrate out of the city but it could
also have been a mixture of floods
earthquakes and the bubonic plague
hopefully not all at once that would
have been a really bad week so an ku is
left to rot in the jungle and some books
stayed on in the temple which is most of
what remains of the city today the large
moat that surrounds the holy building
mostly protected it from the encroaching
vegetation and from the bullets and
shells of the Cambodian Civil War
ironically despite all the conservation
work it's now under more threat than
ever since all of those tourists
marching over the Sun stone and using up
the groundwater are weakening the
building's day by day the damage of 500
years of jungle growth is nothing
compared to what a little kid with a
football and an ice cream can do
okay let's come out of the jungle and
head to higher ground match of peach
juice it's almost two and a half
kilometers above sea level and had a
brief but mysterious history the Incas
built it in 1450 but we are still
unclear as to its purpose since the
site's although very beautiful has no
real strategic benefit in terms of trade
or food or power perhaps it was just a
king trying to be difficult
you know how Kings are the most likely
reason is that it was some sort of royal
retreat like the US presidents Camp
David or Hitler's Eagle Nest up in the
mountains of Bavaria no Eagles for the
Incas though they had the large stone
altar of the Condor where they would
perform human sacrifices and the birds
would come and remove the carcasses the
Incas were quite advanced and the
construction of some of Machu Picchu
temples is so accurate that you can't
even fit a sheet of paper between the
stonework meaning it holds together
without mortar the steps terraces of the
city are also a very smart way of
adapting the mountain to the needs of
the city surprisingly their civilization
never got around to inventing the wheel
although perhaps if you're over two
kilometres up a hill the last thing you
wanted to see your cart rolling off down
into the nearest valley in just over 100
years this city was deserted possibly
due to the devastation caused by
smallpox which to conquest adores
brought with them from Spain what a
lovely welcome gift on to Italy now and
into a bay on the west coast that also
holds the city of Naples Naples has
existed in some form for around 3,000
years making it one of the longest
continuously inhabited places on earth
but across the other side of the bay
lies Pompeii and Pompeii was not quite
so lucky in 79 AD the entire Roman city
was destroyed and buried under a huge
mound of ash and pumice up to six meters
deep killing some 16,000 people when
Mount Vesuvius erupted a mixture of ash
stones and gases were blown 33
kilometres into the air and in an
astonishing 1.5 million tons of pumice
and Malta
rakh were spat out of the volcano every
second this ended the 500 year history
of Pompeii having been built at some
point around 700 and 600 BC so I guess
some of you are thinking why build your
city next to a giant volcano that just
seems like you're asking for trouble
well it was actually a pretty quiet
volcano then since the previous eruption
had been a relatively small one almost
200 years before still 16 years before
the eruption that destroyed Pompeii
there was a huge earthquake that took
out a lot of the city and led to looting
and chaos this was less a red flag more
an entire flag factory making 10 meter
square banners saying move away from the
giant fire bucket excavation of the city
began in 1738 when workmen discovered it
whilst digging the foundations for a
Summer Palace it's a huge tourist
attraction with much of the art and
buildings restored Vesuvius hasn't
erupted since 1944 but with 30 separate
eruptions in 79 AD this voracious
volcano shows no signs of stopping and
poses an enormous threat to the 3
million people who now live within 20
miles of its crater for our next city we
traveled to the deserts of Jordan Petra
was a city card into the walls of
looming sandstone which form a natural
fortress around it it's lay on the key
Caravan route through to Gaza and the
Red Sea so it was the center of
Nabataean trade the Nabataeans were
described as one of the most gifted
people of the ancient world and it's
hard to argue with the petra we see now
of stunning tombs caught of beautiful
detail and ingenious waterways that made
an arid land thrive was probably built
around the 1st century at the same time
in ancient Britain we were pretty
pleased that the Romans had invaded so
we didn't have to live in a circle of
modern sticks anymore
the tombs and temples are often much
smaller inside than their grand
entrances which suggests despite this
experts believe that we have only
uncovered around 15% of what is there
there are many secrets yet to be found
some Bedouin tribes believe
there is treasure in the rocks and you
can see the bullet holes where they have
tried to shoot it out the Romans came
along in 106 a day and the city began to
empty as its importance as a trade route
decreased and by 700 AD it was consigned
to history if you don't want to make the
long journey to see the ancient city
you'll be glad to know it's on Google
Street View so you can enjoy some of its
wonders without even having to get
dressed our final two cities have more
of an air of mystery around them since
we have no definitive proof that they
actually existed nor do we know exactly
where they could have been our first
legend is the magical city of gold El
Dorado in the earlier versions of the
story El Dorado was a man and may have
been the king of the native moisture
people a tribe from near modern-day
Bogota in Colombia when a new king was
appointed he would be covered in gold
dust and then dipped into the waters of
Lake Guatavita while his unlock is also
fearing gold jewelry from the mid 16th
century and for hundreds of years after
many attempts to find a city were made
but nothing was ever found a lot of the
myth was fueled by the fact that the
conquest adores so many of the local
people wearing gold without seeming to
understand its value so they assumed
there must be some huge touch of it
somewhere one failed attempt resulted in
the discovery of a great river and when
a tribe of warrior women chased the
Explorers off their similarity to a
Greek myth was noted and the river was
named the Amazon the English explorer
Sir Walter Raleigh led to great
expeditions to Venezuela aiming to find
El Dorado and to establish an English
colony in South America and disrupt the
Spanish trade with the native people on
the second journey he was on strict
orders not to get into any battles with
the Spanish due to the delicate politics
back home rally stayed on the island of
Trinidad but his son was killed in an
inevitable fight with the Spanish when
rally returned home he was beheaded for
disobeying orders I'm not quite sure
what they really expected though
fighting the Spanish was pretty much a
national pastime around
since the city of El Dorado proved
impossible to find many resorted to
searching Lake Guatavita
there were many attempts but surely the
best was when a London company drained
the whole lake in 1898 and were annoyed
to find that the remaining mud baked as
hard as concrete in the jungle Sun
making it almost impossible they
uncovered a pathetic 500 pounds worth of
gold for their efforts they probably
made more money and free drinks when
they told the story in the pub back home
and finally the most famous lost city of
them all Atlantis the legend of an
island lost to the sea has kept going
for thousands of years but no evidence
has ever been found and there is a
general consensus amongst historians
that it has no real basis in truth its
origin is largely down to the Greek
philosopher Plato who discussed an
imaginary Island as part of his work the
Republic which he used to explore the
idea of a perfect state in the story
ancient Athenians are the only people
able to defend against Atlantean attack
and the island itself loses favor of the
gods who decided to submerge it into the
Atlantic Ocean probably a bit harsh but
then Greek gods aren't exactly famous
for their calm demeanor and balanced
decision making they were far too
engrossed with drinking incest and
making animals with lots of heads
plato's story stuck though and there
have been hundreds of proposed sites for
this lost city everywhere from the
Mediterranean to the Antarctic and even
the Bermuda Triangle the people of
Atlantis were rumored to be a
technologically advanced super race with
submarines and aircraft but if they were
so smart why didn't they do something
when they notice two sea levels were
rising around them or maybe they did and
we just haven't found them yet I want to
give a quick shout-out to audible.com
who are helping to support me which
helps me to make better content in the
future they have over 180,000
downloadable audiobooks across all
genres lately I've been listening to
Bill Bryson's a short history of nearly
everything which is a fascinating and
humorous journey through the history of
the universe and
scientific development if you want to
try it out audible are offering a free
30 days of scription
just go to audible.com forward slash
forty or click the link in the
description below I've been driving a
lot lately and I found that audiobooks
are a fantastic way to pass the time
whilst traveling so give it a shot
thanks to the view subscribe for more 42